some high-profile fans got to see modern
warfare 2 early and warzone weapon nerfs
are making some players upset
the reveal of modern warfare 2's logo
made a pretty big splash on social media
yesterday later in the day the game made
another more subtle appearance at the
2022 nfl draft in the form of clothing
ahmad gardner of cincinnati wore a call
of duty task force 141 pin while evan
neal of alabama wore a call of duty task
force 141 pocket square ohio state's
garnett wilson dressed up his outfit
with a call of duty ghost pin while kyle
hamilton of notre dame wore a suit with
task force 141 printed on it now if you
didn't know task force 141 is the main
protagonist group of earlier modern
warfare titles the modern warfare 2019
campaign ended with price looking to set
the unit back up modern warfare games
typically go to a number of places
around the globe and based on a hidden
message in the animation that revealed
the new logo mw2 will potentially
include singapore before the draft
gardner revealed on his instagram story
that he was among the first people in
the world outside of activision to see
the new call of duty game in a
subsequent tweet gardner said quote it
was so realistic it's insane he then
added that a new warzone game is coming
this year as well and gardner if you're
watching this and you happen to take a
couple secret pics of the game i just
want to say my twitter dms are open and
i promise not to leak the pics and while
i wait for that dm to come through let's
talk about the current call of duty the
season 3 update for call of duty warzone
made some pretty significant changes to
the battle royale including a ton of
weapon balancing unfortunately some
players are frustrated with the sniper
nerfs that arrived within those weapon
changes specifically a nerf to
completely remove the ability for one
shots to the head for modern warfare's
rytek amr and dragon off snipers as well
as black ops cold wars m82 sniper rifle
this reddit user voiced their
frustrations asking why the amr's 20
millimeter explosive round can't deliver
one shot to the head at range the user
also shared a clip showing the amr in
action post nerf to reveal how badly the
change has impacted the sniper of choice
some users commented to question whether
the developer is making changes to
ensure vanguard guns of the meta with
the hope of boosting sales however
season 3 sniper meta isn't leaning
towards vanguard snipers at all modern
warfare's hdr and ax-50 sniper rifles
are quickly becoming more popular
choices especially for sniping across
caldera alright hard transition here to
free games microsoft has unveiled the
games with gold lineup for may 2020.
these freebies include yoko's island
express which marries pinball mechanics
with the side-scrolling adventuring of
metroidvanias the inner world the last
wind monk a point-and-click adventure
set in a world led by the flute nose
dynasty viva pinata party animals a
mario party s game that was originally
released for the xbox 360 and hydro
thunder hurricane an xbox live arcade
boat racing game that aims to be chaotic
rather than realistic yogo and hydro are
available on may 1st while inner world
and party animals will be up for grabs
on may 16th now completely unrelated to
today's topic should i be getting into
sea of thieves because i like pirates
but the game never really piqued my
interest and like i know it's changed a
lot over time so let me know if i should
be getting into it and if you want to
carry me through some missions i'll see
you next week